[Music]
we train people to perform complicated
underwater egress movements we ask
people to confront what can be some
pretty primal stuff fear of darkness
confined spaces fear of water and all
happening simultaneously and we take
away their ability to see and it can
play a little bit into the things that
they are afraid of at survival systems
us a SWAT Coast Guard and Marine units
learn basic steps for underwater
survival the primary tool is
custom-built helicopter simulator but in
order to make these passengers safe
they'll be put in danger first we'll
experience what it takes to survive and
over the water aircraft survival
situation and then we'll take a peek
behind the curtain and getting even
deeper understanding of what goes into
creating and maintaining such a
high-stakes training system this is
damage control
I'm Albert Bohemia I'm the founder of
survival systems started in 1982 when I
was in the military I was one of my jobs
was their crew life support and I knew
that there were many problems with that
equipment and I also knew that the
passengers had no training after I left
the military I was flying to the Arctic
and I did attempt to land on top of a
mountain basically crashed I survived
the crash because of my military
training and the way I had been drilled
in - even though you don't think it's
ever gonna happen to you always be
prepared to react I understood from
personal experience that unless you're
very ready you may not do the right
thing Bohemia built this simulator so he
could provide training for
servicemembers first responders and
others who might experience forest water
landings and he built it in such a way
that it accurately simulates real danger
their training is called underwater
egress or simply water egress the
simulator is as realistic as we can make
it without actually making it into a
helicopter or an aircraft the mechanisms
operate the way they do on the aircraft
so if a handle spins in the aircraft the
handle will spin inside the simulator if
you fly next to a door that's 22 inches
across the simulator exit for that door
will be 22 inches across
so when a student shows up for training
they'll enter the simulator and they'll
either be seated next to an exit or
they'll be seated one seat or two seats
away from an exit so we have them buckle
in we assumed that there's an over water
emergency they get into a brace position
we have an impact with the surface of
the water and subsequent rollover
through the course of the day we we
start with baby steps we work on the
easy stuff first procedures first and
then we start applying those procedures
under more and more complicated
scenarios
the most common and the biggest mistake
that I see people make they try to get
that seatbelt off as quickly as possible
when that happens you lose all reference
to the rest of the airframe it's very
easy for a person to become disoriented
and end up right-side up inside of an
upside-down aircraft proprioceptive
disorientation is a factor that impacts
a person's ability to perform an
underwater egress
it's our awareness of our body position
in space in under those circumstances
it's really difficult to figure out
where you are relative to everything
else and find the emergency exit the
average person does know exactly where
they are until they physically start the
process of reorienting themselves it's a
bit like if you don't touch the edge of
your bed and the headboard of your bed
you don't know where you are if all you
feel is blankets and sheets it's the
same thing in a helicopter if you
release your seatbelt you don't know
where your exit anymore
this disorientation is one of the first
and most critical issues trainees face
the technology they use was designed to
guarantee disorientation once you hit
the water so we wanted to disorient the
average human being a hundred percent of
the time so as you were safely strapped
into this machine and you were elevated
above the water and we lowered you we
have to continue the speed of this hint
at the same rate and whilst we were
pulling you on the water and pulling you
upside down we had to make you lose your
vision make you lose your sensory input
so that you didn't know anymore whether
you're up down or sideways and now we
start teaching you how do I get out of
here there are several factors of
disorientation happening simultaneously
- especially in a rollover situation one
we have visual disorientation we lose
two-thirds of our visual acuity when
we're submerged immediately color also
starts to disappear as
descend through the water column and red
is the first color that disappears it
happens at ten or twelve or fifteen feet
or so and a lot of emergency exits
placards handles are all marked red so a
person under those circumstances are
maybe looking around and they're seeing
purple or black or blue the survival
systems course retrains the brain to
enact a series of simple processes when
disoriented and under intense stress the
main things that we recommend that
people do to help overcome that or want
to stay in the seat belt buckled into
your seat as long as possible because as
long as you're buckled into the seat you
know where you are relative to
everything else in the aircraft and
that's a good starting point for
performing the egress secondarily we
recommend using an anatomical reference
point to be to work our way towards and
exit I would tell people if you're
confused touch yourself yeah these are
my legs and if these are my legs this is
where my seat belt is this is my seat if
my seat is here this is where my exit is
once they jettison the exit they need to
make sure that they have an open exit to
find their way out so they'll grab the
frame their other hand will come down
and work the harness they'll either spin
it or they'll pull the latch and they'll
release their harness once they've done
that and now they can pull themselves
out so the disorientation can continue
to affect somebody after they've
performed the underwater egress and
we've seen this in the training
environment where somebody who pulled
himself clear the exit and started
swimming towards the bottom of the pool
Bohemia says he felt that disorientation
when he crashed to during the disaster
situation after I crashed I was
completely dysfunctional as a human
being I couldn't think I could not
organize myself the only way I could
come to any type of structured reaction
was to write down on my knee pad I have
crashed I now have to survive
I have to make a plan so I realized how
training and being able to do emergency
reaction to a threatening
life-threatening situation how important
it is that you've thought about it the
training he developed depends on the
technology underlying it Albert wanted
to be absolutely certain that what he
built would put trainees into the
correct frame of mind and give them as
close to a real experience as possible
he knew that lives depended on it so
it's a very nice elegant integrated
system crane operator the divers the
instructors how they communicate and how
they use the safety features that are
built into the crane things like they're
redundant wire ropes the weight of the
crane the emergency stop they are all a
nice integrated system that allows all
of the redundancies to make it easy for
us to train somebody and not hurt the
engineer to control the system that
safely emulates a dangerous environment
it also goes back to the classroom
discussion with the instructor part of
what we do and I think we do it
particularly well is establishing
rapport with the students in the
classroom to have them come up to you
and tell you as the instructor I don't
know how to swim great we can work with
that I know how to swim but I am
terrified of this we can work with it
just have faith in us and get in the
simulator the first time we will walk
you through Anna I always remember one
of the Canadian military aircrew who he
came he took a course and I was an
instructor and he kept jumping out of
the simulator every time we would call
ditching and start lowering the machine
he would jump up and at one point he got
really angry and he left the site he
didn't came back the next day and said
listen is there anything you can do to
help me finish and we did we worked with
him for almost a whole day until we
could get him upside down on the water
he could stop his panic for years later
I was training in the pool and this dude
came by and stood on the pool deck and
said hey come over and he said oh I just
want to thank you man you saved my life
my kids have a father because of what
you did and he said I was hateful I was
hateful to what you did to me
in that machine but he said only during
the final moment of death versus life I
understood why you guys design your
machine - we did and also did the
training - what you did
I had to crash to really understand it
survival systems has created a safe
simulation and detailed system of
protocols for one of the most dangerous
things that can happen to you in a
helicopter nothing they do here can
prevent emergencies from taking place
but by training for dangerous situations
like ditching a helicopter escaping an
onboard fire and other worst-case
scenarios they're providing helicopter
pilots and passengers with tools that
might just help them walk away from a
disaster
[Music]